Ready?
Set.
Go!
Don't jump!
Whoa!
Hey, why would you do that?
[inaudible] Oh, medical!
Medical!
We need the medical up top.
There's been a collision.
I hit my nose on something.
Yeah.
Go ahead and pull
my glasses off.
Cut your eye on your glasses.
Is that what it is?
Sure did.
Yeah, it might need a stitch.
Let me know when
I get him in for it.
Like any form of
motor sports, crashes,
bangs, and things take place.
We have safety equipment.
You wear helmets, you
wear safety belts,
you wear all the stuff.
We have roll bars.
But that doesn't make
it perfectly safe.
The key to any
emergency is being
able to get there quickly,
so we've got Matt here,
one of the firemen on set.
You guys are out
here every day, huh?
Absolutely.
Every day that they're
running, we're out here.
We've also got access
to helicopters,
and we can land them out
here, just about anywhere.
So by the time we get
the patient stabilized,
the package, that helicopter
can be on the ground,
loaded up, and ready to go.
Right on.
Well, thanks for
being on board, and we
really appreciate you guys.
Absolutely.
Yeah, man.
Thank you, guys.
David's cleared
medical protocol.
He's ready to continue.
Went to Georgia, and
all I came home with
was this lousy scar.
Ready?
Set!
Go!
Come on!
You gotta go!
It's a race!
I hurt my neck.
Man, we have a lot of
carnage on the course, guys.
I got a bad pain in my neck.
All right.
Medical, medical.
All right, guys,
paramedics are coming
in to take the driver away.
Wiggle your toes.
Wiggle one.
- Yep.
All that's good.
- Everything good?
Yep.
You wanting to
go to the hospital?
- Yeah.
- All right.
You see motorsports on TV,
and you don't think it's real.
But the reality is
here on Truck Night,
these vehicles are,
in fact, jumping.
They are hitting the ground.
They are doing things
they're not necessarily
supposed to be doing.
And, in fact, there is a
consequence occasionally.
We are en route
to the hospital.
Our firemen are trained.
We have an extrication vehicle.
We've got basic
first aid vehicles,
and they're ready
to go at all times.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
This is where it's going to
make or break him, right here.
Oh!
He pulled the back
tires off the ground.
He planted that
cross member right
on top of the rollercoaster.
I'm stuck.
That's it.
You did awesome, dude.
You did awesome.
We're going to get
you out of here.
Excavator!
We have a kick-ass
recovery team that comes in
to get these things
out here, and they
have a lot of vehicles to
choose from to help them
get these rigs out of here.
We've got a pickup,
we got a buggy,
we have excavators--
heck, we even have dozers.
And these guys use whatever
it takes to get them free.
Once they get that
cross member unstuck,
he'll come right off of there.
You've got some
heavy machinery,
but it takes a light touch.
These operators are amazing
here on Truck Night.
Well, there it is.
Just that easy.
Use your excavator, pop
him out of that thing.
Recovery did their
job great once again,
and we're off to play.